Learner B1: بلو.
Learner B3: ضوء الأخبار.
Learner B1: اي و انت و ابوك.
Learner B3: الحمد لله تمام.
Learner B1: الحمد لله.
Learner B2: السلام عليكم شباب النور.
Learner B3: وعليكم السلام. الحمد لله تمام.
Learner B2: إمم فرانك.
Learner B1: في اليوم.
Learner B6: إلى مصر.
Learner B2: إحنا ننقص تقريبا ندى ون.
Learner B3: وزينب.
Learner B2: زينب بتدخل ميتينغ صح؟
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B1: ظرف ما.
Learner B2: مش متأكد أنها تدخل السرعة
Learner B2: مش طيب هذا في الميتينج ده كان المفروض حاجتين ستاند أب مع مدى
Learner B2: وسيرفيه عن الاسئلة بتاعتكم كحد من أو
Learner B2: التين المسؤول او اللي بدأت فكرة الانت
Learner B2: فنرد على المسألة دي على اساس ريبورتو ويبقى معاكو اكشن داتا فريديتد تقدروا تشتغلوا بيها من تبعيتنا يعني
Learner B2: فده الهدف يعني إن إحنا نجمع الحاجات دي كلها ونقدر معاكم
Learner B2: خليني كدا النظرة سريعة شوف لو هي تدخل عشان
Learner B2: تبدأ يعني بالفندق أو ناكس نشوف الله يسلمك
Learner B2: ماشي يعني ما ردتش خليني أبدأ بالجزء الثاني أو الجزء بتاع الأول فا ممكن تتصل الو.
Learner B1: الصوت تمام.
N.Learner B4: هلو؟ هلوا يا شباب.
Learner B3: هل لي أن أدعم.
Learner B1: إمم.
N.Learner B4: الحمد لله والله.
Learner B3: الحمد لله تمام.
N.Learner B4: يقدر يتصل.
Learner B3: تمام.
Learner B1: شغالين عليهم شغالين.
N.Learner B4: دي حاجة واقفة معاكم حاجة محتاجين أي حاجة.
Learner B3: لا لا تستلمي لغاية دلوقتي.
Learner B1: إنجرام.
N.Learner B4: أنا زي الفل.
Learner B1: يا رب.
Learner B3: نكران زينب أم.
Learner B2: بتحبوا جزء الأول ولا الجزء أو الأسئلة اللي إنت عايز هنا.
Learner B3: أنا عن نفسي حاسة إن إحنا ممكن نبدأ بالسرفي.
Learner B2: أنا معك.
N.Learner B4: أنا بتفق معك يا مرام.
Learner B3: تمام.
N.Learner B4: نبدا بالسلفيه يا شباب زي الفل عادل تمام نبدأ بالسيد
N.Learner B4: وبعد ذلك أيضا حاتم عنده حاجة أو شيء.
Learner B2: مثلا خلاص تمام خلوني أديلكم كده عن برودكت نفسه أتأكد بس إنتو سامعيني كويس
Learner B2: هو عايز أقولكوا احنا منبيع الانت تو بي مثلا أو ال
Learner B2: الشركات الاخرى انتو عارفين فكرة بشكل عام من أي اتش ار او من اي شركة
Learner B2: وعادة ممكن تخل او توصل مش كويسة
Learner B2: فبالتالي ده الشركة شركة نيغاتيف على المدى الطويل واربعين،
Learner B2: فكان الهدف أو ما كنا بنحاول نعمله هو ان احنا
Learner B2: نكريت سينيوشن بعيشك في شغل الشركة من قبل ما تلتحق بيها.
Learner B2: فنقدر نشوف بتاعك نقدر ناخد من كتيرة جدا عندك بتاعك فده يكون سيغنال أو قوي بالنسبة لينا كستيك هولدرز مثلا عايزين نغير في تيم اكس او واي أو زي
Learner B2: وهي دي التجربة اللي إحنا بدأناها في معانا كتير في كذا قسم
Learner B2: أو كان في الصيف يبقى بنشتغل مع عدد من الإنترنت فبدأنا في أكتر من وبقى الناس اللي بتثبت كفاءتها في انتيرشن إحنا بقى كشركة كأن بنطبق علينا مناخدها
Learner B2: تشتغل في التين لمدة مثلا شهر شهرين تلاتة حسب بقى
Learner B2: فهو ده كان فكرة السيليشيوشن ودي كانت التجربة ان هو يبقى ووركسي ميديشن المحاكم ديتعمل شركة ويبقى كاست مايبل أي شركة تقدر تستخدمه تحط بروجكتس بتاعتها تدخل وهكذا فنقدر نساعدها إنها تغير وبالفعل، بدأنا نشتغل في ده
Learner B2: مع شركات في مصر وفي السعودية زي مثلا شركة برك سيستمز
Learner B2: في شركة تقريبا كان اسمها قارب أو
Learner B2: قرى يعني أكتر من شركة بتشتغل في مجال إي آي أو التكنولوجي حتبدأ تستخدم ده عشان توصل لنتائج فده كان فكرة من هنا بقى ممكن
Learner B2: أسمع أسئلتكم بيست على انتو اللي احنا عملنا هيدي.
Learner B3: أنا عندي سؤال هو أنت قلت إن في متعاقدين معاكوا عشان ياخدوا برضه بس أنا.
Learner B2: في.
Learner B3: ما فهمتش قوي الحتة دي يعني وإحنا مفروض على فهل يعني المقصود إن بيبقى في ولا هم برضه عندهم حاجة شبيهة واخدينها إينسبيرت باي سبرينس.
Learner B2: هقولك هو بيجي يقول لنا أنا عايز أغير مثلا تلاتة مثلا يعني وال بادجت بتاعتي اكس هم
Learner B2: فإحنا بنبدأ على بنعمل أول حاجة كول لازم تبدأ تقدم على الانتنشونال انتيرشن
Learner B2: بعد كده نبدأ بصدده دلوقتي لمدة شهر أو تلات أسابيع 6 أسابيع على حسب
Learner B2: ونجمع بقى إينسايكس وفيدس من ال إي آي ومن الكوتشز اللي حيكونوا موجودين
Learner B2: عشان نوصل للشركة دي حتغيره فهي او توب ثري بقى فبتبدأ تاخد من هنا، فهي الشركة بتدينا بروجرام ستتمنت وبتدينا
Learner B2: يعني الحاجة اللي عايزينه وهكذا واحنا بس هو عشان كده إنتو بروجكتوا مثلا ناس فاضية بيعملوا بيعملوا مثلا باستخدام ال إي آر
Learner B2: حاجة في البزنس بتاع مثلا الناس بتاعت الماركتينغ بتعمل كامبين
Learner B2: فهي كل بيزنس بتتحط بتبقى تبع الشركة اللي راوند دي واللي فاتت شركة في براونز جاية إن شاء الله
Learner B2: حيبقى معها فرد ناس تانيين دي بروبليم.
Learner B3: أوكي تمام.
Learner B2: طبعا
Learner B2: ماشي ممكن بقى أبدأ أسمع أسئلتكم اللي ممكن تساعدكم في
Learner B2: في السيرفي اللي انتم حابين تبدؤوه أو يعني تساعدكوا في السرفيه بشكل عام عشان بروجكت والكريديشن وات
Learner B2: فإيه الحاجة اللي ممكن يعني أسمع أسئلتكم يعني عن ال برودكت أو ال لو محتاجين أي
Learner B2: فاليديشن هوداتك أو حاجة تمام.
Learner B1: هو معلش في الشركة إشتريت برودكت ده ولا.
Learner B2: في عليهم شركتين في وحدة حتبدأ قريب. إسمها برك سيستم.
Learner B1: ما بورت سيستم.
Learner B2: بارك سيستم.
Learner B1: كل.
Learner B2: وفي اتنين في 1 منهم أبروفت والتاني في الفاينر ثري
Learner B2: دي الشركة ألريدي اشترت حطيتلهم إنه في بوست؟ تنازل عالسوشال ميديا بتاعتنا واحنا بنساعد معها.
Learner B3: طيب أنا عندي كده سؤال ليه علاقة. هل بقى إحنا بنرجعلكوا منرجع تيكنيكال تيم إزاي بتتقال.
Learner B2: من ناحية إيه.
Learner B3: يعني أنا مثلا عملت لمشكلة معينة على أي أساس. أعرف هي فعلا يعني موضوع سهل يتعمل
Learner B3: ولا ممكن يبقى لأ ادفانس شوية. هل تيم أو تيكنيكال تيم حيقدر إن هو يطبق فعلا البورتي تايب ده ولا لأ عشان أنا أقول.
Learner B2: إنتو ألريدي عملتوا حاجة زي كده.
Learner B3: هو إحنا شغالين على بروتوتي تايب دلوقتي أنا مش عارفة بقية ال تيم هل هم
Learner B3: يعني خلصوا حاجة معينة لا بس إحنا كنا عرضنا آخر مرة يعني نحنا وصلنا له أوتي تايب.
Learner B2: أكيد هيبقى جزء منو هون أنت.
Learner B3: بالزبط.
Learner B2: إنت.
Learner B3: وإحنا بنعرض عايزة مثلا أقول إن هو ده ده يبقى
Learner B3: اللي هو مثلا بالنسبة للتقسيم هيبقى الموضوع سهل حياخد منهم وقت قد يعني عايزة يبقى في مقياس كامل كده وأنا بشرح يعني
Learner B3: أشرح قد الموضوع يبقى سهل أو صعب إن هو يبقى أبلايد يعني.
Learner B4: يعني لو في معينه وفي معينه
Learner B4: دي ممكن ناخذها بروتوتيب حوالين الموضوع. أنا سألت باش مهندس محمد مرزوق بالمناسبة عن موضوع الديمو دي ح يمشي ولا جروب بس قالي هم.
Learner B2: هو بالنسبة للمرة اللي فاتت
Learner B2: يعني كل حد آي بريسنت من.
Learner B4: هل بالنسبة لكم مهم؟ إن البروتو طيب يبقى دوبل ولا منحط شيركل
Learner B4: كل الأيديز اللي عندنا وذاكاي إز أور ليميت وخلاص لو في أي حاجة محتاجين.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B2: لا تيكنيكال في زميلتي دي مش مش فاكتور يعني
Learner B2: المهم ناخذه في الاعتبار من وجهة نظري لأن احنا لسا في المراحل المبدئية وركشنز
Learner B2: بس إنتوا ممكن لو حد حابب يعمل رف إستمد،
Learner B2: فأنتوا اللي انتو مثلا بتستخدموها دلوقتي دي مثلا خدت راوند تلات شهور ديفيل ركن
Learner B2: ده ممكن يديلكم اللي إنت عامله ده ياخد قد تقريبا في
Learner B2: وأعتقد ما فيش حاجة صعبة تتعمل يعني في عصر الجي آي الحمد لله
Learner B2: يعني أي شي مهما كانت صعبة مسألة بس وقت وتستينغ تتعمل فده ممكن يديلكو ونسايت كده
Learner B2: يعني أنتم بتدربونا بنفترض.
Learner B3: أوكي ميك سينس بس هو برضه من فيدباك برضه بيت التي مصلحلي يعني لو
Learner B3: لو فاكرة صح إنه إحنا نعرف هل ده أبليكيبل أو إن إحنا يعني نعرف دي ثيلس أكتر فهو مثلا لو إنتو بتم يعني بتعملوا راوند كل شهر
Learner B3: ففي مثلا، مشاكل بتواجههم بتواجه الراوندي هتعملوا راوند قريب تاني فمحتاجين اللي هو لا يبقى في خلال حرفين كم أسبوع
Learner B3: بالذات إن أنا لما تواصلت مثلا مع يوزر كان خد الإنترنت اللي فاتت لحس إن هو في مشاكل برضه أو ما صلحتش فولي
Learner B3: فاهمنا قصدي إيه.
Learner B2: فاهم قصدك ما هي الفكرة بتبقى فين دي تبقى مهمة البرودكت أومر
Learner B2: ممكن تكون فيتشر أو الإيشو دي بالنسبة لل
Learner B2: لليوزر ده مثلا يعني حاجة عملها ريبورتينغ فشايف إن هي المفروض تتصلح
Learner B2: بس بكون بقلبك لوغ انتو فاهمين أكيد الحتة والردمان بيكون فيها حاجات أكتر
Learner B2: ممكن تكون يعني مثلا في فيتشر مؤخرا عملناها
Learner B2: ان بقى المنتور هو اللي بيدخل يكلم الليجنت ويرفع له التاسكات ويحدد ديدلاين وياخد منها فيدباك عنكو وعن ال وعنجمت والتسكات اللي انتو عملتوها.
Learner B2: وهكذا فممكن إنتو مش شايفين فيتشارد بس دي كانت جدا في الباكلوك لأن هي كانت
Learner B2: على تيم وحتحس إن إكسبيرينس بتاعة المنت
Learner B2: فبرضه ده برضه يعني محتاجين تاخدوه في ممكن مثلا حمدي يقول مثلا يعني إن في
Learner B2: زوم بهنب معاه يعني فدي ممكن تكون شوف
Learner B2: بسيطة ولزوم هي المشكلة مش فاهمين قصدي فهي مسألة يعني
Learner B2: فكده كدا تيم عنده ميكروغ من فيتشرز وال في
Learner B2: بس ال بتكون دايما الأولويات فينا إن إحنا نسير تايم دي بتكون أولوية إختيار أي فيتش وده أعتقد يعني
Learner B2: أي بيزنس حيبص للموضوع. ده أنا عايز أسير على تشتغل فيكون البزنس أكتر.
Learner B3: طب إحنا مثلا لو قبل حبينا إن إحنا برضه نتأكد إن نقيسها يعني حتى لو إحنا عادي ممكن حاجات ما تبقاش أبليكيبل قوي بس لو إحنا حابين برضه حاجة معينة نقيس على أي مدى هل إحنا ممكن نشارك مع التقسيم أو كده
Learner B3: ويدينا مثلا برسنتاج.
Learner B3: حتى لو بيرسنت أكيود.
Learner B2: هو ما انتشروها في صورة
Learner B3: لأ يعني مثلا إحنا شفنا خلاص جمعنا ال يوزير فيدباك مثلا، عرفنا إن هم في مشكلة معينة، فأنا عملت فأنا عايزة أعرف ده ممكن يطبق مثلا تمام ولا لأ.
Learner B2: هو هو أنا من تيكستينغ فأنا ممكن ده فلو إنتو عندكو يوزر ستوريز مكتوبة ممكن أبص عليها يعني
Learner B2: بس زي ما قلتلك دي ممكن تبقى حاجة ليكو انتو تو هافيت يعني بس إحنا مش حاجة زي كده في مثلا يعني مثلا نفترض في 1 عمل
Learner B2: فيري فيزيبل فؤاد صغير
Learner B2: بس ما فيهوش فيتشرز فده اقل من 1 عمل مثلا حاجات فيها بتاعها مش اعلى يعني اعلى بس مش بكتير من الشخص الأول،
Learner B2: فأعتقد الفاكتور هنا بالنسبة يوزر سينتريك وإن إنت تكون
Learner B2: يعني يمكن اصلا الاساسي في اي شركة سوفتوير هو الخناعه البي ام وال تكريت ستعملها ازاي اقوله لا اعملها بالطريقة هذه
Learner B2: فكده كده مش يعني المفروض ان انتوا تبقوا انتو
Learner B2: ان انتم يعني هدفكم ان انتوا توصلوا للاحسن إكسبيرينس
Learner B2: وداو قوي إن إنت تبص تيكنيكال في زميلتي على الأقل في الستينج اللي احنا فيها دلوقتي ان احنا عايزين نتفرج على وال يوزر تحت والبزنس أكتر من بس لو حد كاتب يوزر ستوري هو عايز ياخد عليها فيدباك ما فيش مشكلة ممكن على اليمين
Learner B2: وأنا أتشك عليها وأبعت لكم
Learner B2: ولو في كومنتس إنها حاجات مش مضبوطة أو كده رحتركم بس كده كده دي حاجة مش مطلوبة مني.
Learner B3: أوكي تمام.
Learner B2: جميل.
Learner B2: حافظ.
Learner B1: هو في فرق ما بين الراوند دي المفروض الراد التانية صح.
Learner B2: إيه في وكان في روند زيرو.
Learner B1: كان في فرق بينهم.
Learner B2: من ناحية إيه.
Learner B1: مثلا العدد المحتوى الطريقة.
Learner B2: تمام في في فرق في العدد. أنا ممكن أشير معاكوا أكل يفتح بس الماستر فيد ماسك إيش
Learner B2: أنا ممكن أقوم السلام عليكم برضه
Learner B2: فين فين فين فين فين فين فين فين
Learner B2: ماشي راوند ون كانت فيها سبعتاشر أكتي في ليرنين
Learner B2: راوند تو في 65 راوند ثري إكسبكتيد 47 ممكن أكتبله بأرض استيفلو في الغروب أوف
Learner B2: فده بالنسبة لسؤالك في ففي العدد
Learner B2: بروبليمز نفسها هو إحنا بنحاول بأكبر قدر ممكن إن ما فيش تيم يشتغل على بروبليم بتاع تيم تاني
Learner B2: عشان يعني إحنا عندنا الحمد لله بيزنس كتيرة فا
Learner B2: نفسها تختلف يعني مثلا بروجكت انت شغالين عليه. ما كنش نزل في الروند اللي فاتت
Learner B2: وهكذا مثلا ال إي أوي كنا عندنا
Learner B2: اعتقد كان في ثري تيمز بس دلوقتي بقوا تمانية
Learner B2: فزودنا 3 افكار وبقى في أوفر لاب بسيط يعني ممكن 80 بيشتغلوا على نفس الفكرة
Learner B2: فاتوتال دي الوقت إحنا عندنا كم أكتيڤ بروجكت لو مفيد عندنا 6 في وتنين في بروجكت مانجمنت و3 في و1 في فول ستاج
Learner B2: 1 في ال ممكن أبعتلكم أساميهم بردو
Learner B2: بس احنا يعني احنا عملنا مع سكيلين الرقم او عدد الانترنت الموجودين عملنا سكينا على حتة الافكار او ال بيزنس بروبليمز الموجودة عشان
Learner B2: يعني يكون في برضه ما تحولتش بقى لفكرة إن أنا يعني
Learner B2: مشروع بقى الطلبة اللي هو بيتاخذ من راوند فاهمين قصدي
Learner B2: بس بالنسبة لل فيتشرز اللي اضافت ففي في كذا فيتشر من
Learner B2: الجديدة لحد الراوند دي اول حاجة مثلا
Learner B2: ان المينتور يقدر ينشك على ويقدر يبعت اللي أنا حكيته شوية
Learner B2: و ويبعت يعني يشوف المسجسيس بتاعتك مع صورة. ويقدر يبعت من من رسالة
Learner B2: فيقدروا كهيوني أندرو بشكل بشكل كبير يعني
Learner B2: دي فيتشر نزلت جديدة وال فيتشرز بتاعت برضه بتاعة
Learner B2: تقدر ان انت تكلم احمد منصور ويحجزلك 200 جنيه في انه مافيش كونفلت
Learner B2: ويرد عليك باب المواعيد ويبعتلك الهنك وهكذا
Learner B2: ويبعتلك الريكورد لو انت محتاج الريكورد فدي برضو فيتشر مكانش بيعملها دلوقتي
Learner B2: وده كانت حاجة الناس بتسأل عليها كتير الإيه تيغول نحنا القرض لما يبقى لما تعمل توست القرض تتحرك أوتوماتيك
Learner B2: تضم أو لو إنت فوتها معاك دي برضه ضفناهم
Learner B2: في برضو حتة البرسونه بتاعت الكوتش نحن بقينا
Learner B2: بنجمع داتا عن الكوتش ونبقى كأنه الكوتش يعني انت مثلا
Learner B2: بتكلم احمد مرزوق واحنا بقى دلوقتي بنحاول نعمل أكاونت لأحمد مرزوق ندخل يبقى جزء منها. يعني
Learner B2: يعني مثلا هو لو فاضي حيرد ولو هو مش فاضي و فعل نموذج حيبدأ إن هو
Learner B2: اللي إجا يرد مكان أحمد مرزوق بطريقتو بنفس لغتو بنفس أسلوبه
Learner B2: فدي برضو تفيد شرفنا لحتة. إن أنا حيرد بالبرسونا بتاعتو فدي كانت.
Learner B1: معلش هو المنتور ده هو صح؟
Learner B2: لأ المينتر اللي هو ما هو انت عندك
Learner B2: والإي آي أجينت المينتر اللي هي سارة
Learner B2: فإحنا عملنا إيه إن إحنا بقينا من خلال ال أسلوب المرزوق معاكوا ما كابتش للبرسونا بتاعته وحطها فصارت تكلمكوا إنتو تحديدا بالبرسونا بتاعتو كوتش ثاني مثلا منا في ال إي آي
Learner B2: برضو كعملنا بتاعتها وبقى الناس اللي شغالين مع منا اللي هو اسمه سارة نادر بيرد كأنه منا
Learner B2: و حاليا على أكاونتهم الحقيقية، فأنت لو بتكلم أحمد مرزوق ويرد عليك كإيه بأسلوبه
Learner B2: ولو في حاجة هو أو فتح هو أونلاين، وهكذا يرد هو
Learner B2: على حسب هو عايز يبقى يشغل مودل إيجنت أو موديل هيومن فموظيفة يعني
Learner B2: فاهم أنتو مين الإنتر بتاعكو اللي هو أحمد وبيرد كإنه هو المنتو بتاعكو بنفس الأسلوب بتاعوا بنفس اللغة أو هكذا
Learner B2: أنت أصدرتني.
Learner B7: يعني حتى فيدباك بتاعت أي تاك بناخدها من الإيجن.
Learner B2: فيدباك بتاع إيه زي إيه مثلا.
Learner B7: الفيد باك اللي بيوصلنا بعد ما من سميت بناخدو من الإيجانت بس.
Learner B2: ، الفيد باك دلوقتي بيتاخذ من أجنت ولو المشكلة بيبعت رسالة لمرزوق يقول له حيحلها
Learner B2: فدي برضه كانت حاجة برضه ضفنا فيتشر دي اللي هي حتة ال
Learner B2: إن إحنا لو لو نتقابل مشكلة وستراجل معاك في الرد بيفلك إن في مشكلة لل كوتش وال كوتش بيبعت رسالة ويقولها قوليلو كذا أو صححي بالطريقة الفلانية أو إعملي كذا فسارة بتنفذ الإيه
Learner B2: اللي بيقولوا بيقولوا مرزوق فا.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B2: شكرا من الحاجات اللي تفضلي.
Learner B7: تمام المشكلة بيعمل فيدباك المشاكل اللي بتواجهه
Learner B7: يعني الحاجة اللي هو بعد كده بيحولها للي هيومن.
Learner B2: انه ممكن يكون في نوع من أنواع الفاينز هو مش قادر يقراها
Learner B2: زي مثلا لينك 1 بعت لينك برايفت مثلا أو حتى لينك شير
Learner B2: من نوش. أنا شفت حدتي كان يبعتوا مثلا من نوش.
Learner B1: هو اللي.
Learner B2: السلام عليكم.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B3: وقتنا.
Learner B1: يعني.
Learner B2: معك معودلي.
Learner B1: تنظر.
Learner B2: أم طبعا هاي اللينكس سوبورتيد هي بس الدرايف البوبليك إنما أي لينك تاني
Learner B2: مش مكانش بيقدر يفتحه بس احنا برضو اشتغلنا عليها
Learner B2: بقى في بعض اللينكات بيقدر يفتحها عن طريق الويب فيتش طول
Learner B2: وفي بعض الحاجات التانية لأ ما
Learner B2: لازم لو ما عرفش يدخل هيومنت بوتش و ويقدر يهندل هيومن. كنتي يتصرف إزاي.
Learner B7: المشاكل اللي بتواجهه مش بتكون في عدد التذكرات صح
Learner B7: يعني أي طاسة مش بيكون عدده مهما كانت كميته ده بالنسبة له مش مشكلة.
Learner B2: لا، لا، تكنيكالي بتتصحح في ماكسيموم تنينسيل كبير قوي وفيه كثير وكده
Learner B2: وخد وقت. بقى وهكذا لا هو حتة التايمينج دي مش مش تشانج في إن هي بتتعمل
Learner B2: المفروض ان هو يعني لو حصلت كيس فهذه تبقى تكنيكال اير ون تايم تيكنيكال إيرو يعني مثلا السرفر 1 فواحد شاف اني انا بعته محدش رد علي
Learner B2: مرة مثلا تانية كانت حصلت
Learner B2: ان ان حصل مشكلة في في مثلا في كوينغ سيستم أو في حاجة في الباك إن
Learner B2: بس ما سمعش فبتبقى غالبا ون تايم تيكنيكال
Learner B2: المفروض ان هو بيظهر لنا بقى في اللبس أو حد بيبعت لنا دي تيكت لو احنا اتأخرنا
Learner B2: و وتظهر مصنفة نحاول
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B2: بس فهدة العرض دي لا المفروض ان هي مشيوب يشتغلوا يعني ممكن كذا حد يفتح
Learner B2: يعني يبعد في نفس الوقت في نفس العشر دقايق.
Learner B7: تمام يعني مثلا مشكلة اللي هي بعثت لناس كان إن في عدد كبير ممكن يسلم كذا
Learner B7: توسكو في نفس الوقت فده يأخروا في ال
Learner B7: في خروف الرد أيا كان بقى ال إن تيجي على ال على الإنترنت نفسه إيه بس معنى كان المشكلة دي مش موجودة
Learner B7: يعني المشكلة دي كده مش موجودة.
Learner B2: هي المفروض دلوقتي هي مش موجودة يعني أبرت يعني حاجة مفاجئة زي ما قلتلك مثلا وقع في حاجة
Learner B2: الحاجة المتوسطة ديسباتشر حصله الحاجات اللي هي ما حصلتش فالمفروض ان هو بيبعت في 10 دقايق
Learner B2: حتى أنا ممكن أوريكو اللبس بتاعة الكاونت يعني
Learner B2: هتلاقيهم بتوصل في الوقت اللي تزكي.
Learner B7: طيب حضرتك قلت إنه إنه مثلا إن كل المشاكل الموجودة لكل
Learner B7: الراوند بيشتغلوا عليها بتكون مشاكل كتيرة إنتو بتواجهوها فاهم دلوقتي مثلا موجود.
Learner B2: أوكي.
Learner B7: حضرتك قلت في البداية كان كلام مع مريم إنه في كل راوند بيكون في مشاكل مختلفة عن الراوند اللي بعدها ال تيم تاع برودكت بحلوها.
Learner B2: أكيد ما هي بتبقى فيتشرز زيادة بنكتشف انها مطلوبة
Learner B2: أو مشاكل أول مرة تظهر على حسب بقى الكلاسيكيشن يعني بعد 6 أو 4 دقايق
Learner B2: الرد وصل مثلا حتلاقي اغلب الحاجات بتبقى فين
Learner B2: في الرانج ده حصل مشكلة كبيرة يعني
Learner B7: طيب مثلا دلوقتي مشكلة التذكرة بتتأخر دي مش موجودة رغم ان هي كانت طازكا مثلا طيب مثلا دلوقتي في.
Learner B2: للتصحيح. صح.
Learner B7: أم
Learner B7: لا إحنا أخدنا توسك إن هي بتتأخر فإحنا عايزين مشكلة عايزين حل لأن في تذكرة بتتأخر فحماس بيقل لعند متدربين
Learner B7: فإذن.
Learner B2: تقصدي إن هي بتنزلكم متأخر ولا
Learner B7: لا البيد بناخذه متأخر.
Learner B7: فالإذن الإنترنت ويقل دي كانت.
Learner B2: اللي هو زي الفايلوت وهي بترد عليه بالفيباك صح كده.
Learner B7: بالظبط.
Learner B2: لا هي المفروض المشكلة دي كورنت ليه مش موجود
Learner B2: يعني مثلا رديت عليك بعدها بتلات دقايق أو 4 دقايق برضو فيدباك بيوصل مشكله غريبه
Learner B2: اول مرة نواجهها، فأعتقد ان دي حاجة مش كومن يعني لو في حد قتل فيه باك ده مش حيبقى مثلا 70 في المية من الناس بتقول كده فاهمة اصلا.
Learner B7: تمام يعني مثلا التذكر بتاع دلوقتي احنا شغالين عليه إن إحنا نحسن دي حاجة إنتو ما قررتوهاش عشان خاطر إنتو لقيتوا كذا فيدباك سلبي عليها إنتو قررتوها كتحسينات إنتو مقررين تعملوها بس.
Learner B2: لا شوي من أصدقاء ياهن.
Learner B7: يعني مثلا دلوقتي احنا مش شغالين إحنا دلوقتي شغالين على إحنا نعمل شوية يسعدنا إن إحنا نعمل دي بشكل احسن بعد كده.
Learner B2: صح مضبوط مية في المية.
Learner B7: طيب هل دي حاجة إنتو قررتوا انتو تدوهالنا بناء على مشكلة واجهتوها ولا كحاجة انتو حابينها بس تعملوها بعد كده يعني ما كانش في فيدباك سلبي من من راوند فاتت
Learner B7: فعشان كده قررتم تدونا الطسك ده ولا لأ لسه دي حاجة كقرار بس مش أكتر.
Learner B2: لا، لا أخدنا في أكيد نيغاتيف من اللي فاتت فكنا حابين نشوف الينوفيشن بتاعكم زي كدا حيكون اعمل ازاي.
Learner B7: ممكن مثلا لو نعرف إيه الفيد باك اللي خدتوها.
Learner B2: أكيد ممكن أشوف كدا احنا عندنا فيدباك بيبقى في مجموعة من المترسيس كدا بنبص عليها اول حاجه ال
Learner B2: كلاريتي والتسك مانجمنت وال بروجرام ستراكتور وسيركلز إكسبيرينزمنتور ده براميتر كوميونيكيشن ما بين تيم وما بين تيم وسبنس
Learner B2: والإي آي إيجو يعني دي تقريبا أكتر 5 برامج لازم نبص عليه.
Learner B7: أيوه.
Learner B2: أمين ف فالحاجات دي البراومترز اللي جتلنا عليها أكيد فيدبكس
Learner B2: انها محتاجة تتحسن يعني مثلا خلينا نقول مثال في آي أجينز
Learner B2: كان زي ما قلتلك هو مثلا ما كانش بيقرأ اللنكات أو ما كانش بيقرأ حتى
Learner B2: لقيتهم يعني بيعمل جيت هابلينغ أرتس
Learner B2: فإحنا طورناها، عشان تبقى بتقرأ الينكس بتقراب والدرايف. وهكذا
Learner B2: فهكذا يعني بكل فاكتور من دول بيبقى في مثلا حد مثلا هيومنمنتور شيب
Learner B2: ما ما كانوش مثلا فهموهم إزاي مثلا
Learner B2: ف فحاولنا الجاية نديلهم مثلا مفروض نظام ميتينج يبقى عامل ازاي
Learner B2: فهي دي الحاجات اللي كان جالنا فيها فيدباك يعني اللي هي الإجينس والكومونيكيشن وكوبريشن والمنتشيب إندي كرادت
Learner B2: دي الحاجات اللي كان فيها إيش.
Learner B7: ممكن أعرف إيه اللي بالزبط فيمنت أن كلارتي
Learner B7: يعني الفيد باكيت أنا إزاي.
Learner B2: ثانية وحدة ممكن أشوف أتأكد من أنا موجود.
Learner B3: وعايز برضه هل هل حد اشتكى من إكسبينز على سيركل.
Learner B2: أكيد دي من ضمن الحاجات اذا كان فيها
Learner B2: موجودة طالما هي موجودة في ال إيفيلويشن أو أكيد كانت كان فيها كان فيها اشرنا.
Learner B3: بس هو عامة الحاجة يعني لو إنتو كملوا بيها وده يبقى على طول ولا هي بس حاجة مؤقتة.
Learner B2: لا سوفار احنا مكملين بيه فجو.
Learner B7: هو كويس عندي ما كانش مشكلة.
Learner B3: بس أنا كنت بسأل لو في حد أصلا عندو مشكلة معاه أو لأ لأن في حد.
Learner B2: شايفاه مش سهل.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B2: في الاستخدام في ناس بتشتكي من أبليكيشنز مثلا.
Learner B2: حاجات زي كده يعني ماشي أنا حاولت أفلتر كدا على ماشي
Learner B2: أوفمنت بحاول أوصل بس ماشي خلينا ما نسيرش بكلمة طشق
Learner B2: في ناس كانت بتقول انه في بعض التاسكات أوفر لابنغ
Learner B2: تيكنيكال في ناس بتقول الطوسكس شالبي مور كتير إن ما يقدروش فاهمين في جاي ا
Learner B2: ال مثلا في حد برضو كاتب بتبقى بتقترح حاجات أوتوماتيزم كود مش
Learner B2: مش مجرد بس إنك تدي فيك باك جنرال من
Learner B2: كلها على مدار الأربع أسابيع او الخمس اسابيع عارف لستبش بالزبط ، تود
Learner B2: بس فدي آر فيك أند ميديا هيومن انترفينشن
Learner B2: فدي كده بعض الفيدباك أو أغلب حتى فيدباك يعني أم.
Learner B7: كل راوند عملتوها.
Learner B2: الدي كان لا ده الفيدباك بتاعة راوند اللي فاتت.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B2: هي لون فاتت تعتبر كانت أول لوند كبير يعني في لندن قبلها بس كان فيها 5 قصص.
Learner B3: طبعا ممكن أه قولي.
Learner B7: شكرا عاون.
Learner B7: أتوقع إنتو إشتغلتوا عليها
Learner B7: بس فعلا حتة التذكرات فعلا المشكلة دي لسا موجودة لحد دلوقتي اكتر حاجة نشتغل عليها فاهمة.
Learner B2: تحقيق ما ديه كانت المشكلة بتيجي منين من إن في أدمن بياخد الطاسكات بشكل بريف جدا من المنتور
Learner B2: وبيحطها على السيستم فبالتالي بيبقى في ماسينج غبس
Learner B2: فاحنا عملنا الفيتشرت المنتور يخش يحط التاسكات
Learner B2: هو بيدخل بيقول له الطسك لازم كذا كذا عشان تكون كلير
Learner B2: ويحطلها روبريك كمان تغير فيه فباخد بقى
Learner B2: بتاعها وساعتها بيقول أبروف أبروف يرفع ال سيستم ده اللي حصل في ال في السكرينت الرابعة والثالثة تقريبا.
Learner B7: الصباح بس.
Learner B2: المنتور ده اللي هو 1 لكل جروب مع مين مين الشرسة بتسقط هول مينت مرزوق مثلا معك
Learner B2: بضل دايما بحط التشاور.
Learner B7: استغرب هو لما دخل معانا استغرب ان التاسك ليه علاقة هو حس ان التاسسك بعيد اوي. انها غلطة استوردت.
Learner B2: هو الأول أو التاني، أكيد صح؟
Learner B7: أم طيب.
Learner B2: ويمليها التسكوت ويفكروا مع بعض ويرفعوها ال سيستم
Learner B2: وتاخد منو الددلاين وتاخد منو الحاجة كلها اللي محتاج يوضحها و ولو عيطلك في حاجة زي ما قلتلكوا بترجعله
Learner B2: فكأن حرفين عملنا لير كده شلناها بدل ما كان مرزوق ببعض التذكر على طول بياخدو اتوماتيك
Learner B2: فدي حتحل المشكلة ليه لأن هو مرزوق حيبقى
Learner B2: فأكيد هو حيكون أو يربل كتب إيه
Learner B2: لأنه هو هو اللي قالو إعمل كذا
Learner B2: فبالتالي المشكلة دي اتحلت أعتقد في التالتة والرابعة وإنتو تأكدوا إنه برضه.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B2: ده من وجهة نظري مش شايف لو عندكوا انسايت مختلف.
Learner B7: ممكن حضرتك برضه تبعتلنا كنت بدور فيها ولا دي حاجة ما تنفعش.
Learner B2: وأنا رجعتماري طلبت من مني الموضوع ده فرنك بعتوا فعلا
Learner B2: تيم بس حتى الآن لسا هم الموضوع ده
Learner B2: بس غالبا حيكون صعب بس اللي احنا ممكن نبروفايلو
Learner B2: زي ما قلتلك كده إينسايتس انتو انتو الفكرة انتو مش يعني انتو مش تعملوا مثلا داتا يعني فمش محتاجين نيومريكال داتا أو
Learner B2: كاملة حتعملوا بيها مثلا دش بول انتو محتاجين إينسايدز
Learner B2: توجه تفكيركوكت المفروض يبقى شكله عامل ازاي
Learner B2: فال إينسايكس دي ممكن تاخدوها مني او من احمد يوسف
Learner B2: بس ممكن مثلا في صورة ميتينغ في صورة ديبورت او حاجة زي كده
Learner B2: بالحاجات اللي انتوا محتاجينها فده يساعدكو إنو إنتو تحلوا بشكل.
Learner B7: لا أنا مش عايزة أنا مش عايزة تكون في هيئة أركان. أنا كنت عايزة بس كانوت مثلا بس مش أكتر زي مثلا قلنا كذا إن في مشكلة في كذا كانوت بس مش كأرقام أصلا داتا بأرقام بيوزرز بياناتهم لأ مش عايزة ده.
Learner B2: ما ما أنا فاهم ما هي يعني ده برضه يعني
Learner B2: صعب ان شعرها بالفورمات دي لأنه بتبقى برضه
Learner B2: عشان بقولكوا: أعتقد الأهم هو انتوا تاخدوا إينسايد عن المشاكل. يعني أنا أعتقد كل 1 عنده تصور عن مشاكل في باله
Learner B2: فهو عايز يعملها، فاليديشن ومتأكد إن هي موجودة ولا لأ فأنا كان أعتقد
Learner B2: يعني اكتر حاجة ممكن تستفيد منها في ميتينغ ان انت لو عندك حاجة متصور ان دي مشكلة وانت ماني برودكت انت بتحلها
Learner B2: فممكن فكرتك يعني تقولي مثلا انا احل المشكلة دي بالطريقة دي
Learner B2: فسعتها ممكن أقلك إحنا ده مثلا بدأنا فيه ده عملناه ده اصلا ما كانش مشكلة
Learner B2: دي كانت حاجة أبروفت ومش بتتكرر فساعتها. انت تبقى قادر تبني برودكت بتاعك مش على جسمك
Learner B2: فبس اعتقد ده هيكون مفيد اكتر وانتشرحولي برضه.
Learner B7: أين طبعا.
Learner B2: بس قولولي برضه لو
Learner B2: يعني عندكوا إينسايد تاني أو في مثلا حد من يفيد شرنو بيحاول يهل حاجة فحاجة دي مش موجودة مثلا.
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي سؤال.
Learner B2: أم.
Learner B3: هو أولا هو كان في فيدباك عالمنتور هيومن مونترز.
Learner B2: أنا من ضمن الأسبكتلوا معه برضو عشان تبقى معاكوا في ال هذا ممتع.
Learner B3: زي ما زينب بتقولي أنا بحس أي إينسايد هتفيدنا فمش لازم أرقام ولا أسامي ولا أي حاجة فعلا أثبتت المكاتب.
Learner B2: بالزبط أنا بتركو لأسبكس اللي احنا استقبلنا فيها المشاكل والفيك باك
Learner B2: بس ساعات يعني هي الكومنتس وكده دي أنا مش حقدر أشيلها من غير ما تيمي وافق
Learner B2: ما لسه ما ردوش على الحتة دي بس يعني عشان ما انتو ما تحضروش نفسكو
Learner B2: فأنتو يعني خلينا ديسكاس اكتر في
Learner B2: في في المشاكل مثلا أو الفلاديشن بتاع فيتشرز
Learner B2: بقلكم مثلا دي حاجة واحنا فكرنا فيها بنعملها حاجة كانت في حاجة جديدة. فحلوة من انت تحطها تبقى بالنسبة لك في البريزنتيشن كده يعني.
Learner B3: طبعا عندي سؤال هو هل هي اختلفت عن اللي فاتت اختلفت ولا هي هي وإنتو يعني بتحددوا ريكويرمنتس من أول ولا في كل يعني في أول خالص ولا في كل سبرينت.
Learner B2: تقصدي التاسكات أو بروجكت اللي الناس بتشتغل عليه صح.
Learner B3: مظبوط.
Learner B2: لا ده بيكون الحمد من قبلها يعني بيبقى في بروجكتير كوارمنت كده بيتكتب
Learner B2: بيكتبوا بياخد ابروفل عليه من المانجمنت
Learner B2: وعلى اساسه يتحول لتسكات اسبوعية على حسب
Learner B2: يحاول ينفذ المشروع ده معنتو بشكل أسبوعي
Learner B2: وحد مثلا شاطر خلص ممكن يديلو وحدة تانية
Learner B2: يقسم التاشقط على يومين تلاتة في الأسبوع ممكن بقى المنتور يتحكم في الحاجات دي كلها
Learner B2: بس الفكرة انه يخلص المشروع اللي بدؤوا
Learner B2: أو الخط بروجكتور في الأول خالص
Learner B2: فهي بتكون بلند يعني لو السؤال هنا بتكون بلندن من الأول أو بتكون من قبل ما تبدا.
Learner B7: طيب أهلا وسهلا.
Learner B3: ، قولي.
Learner B7: بولندي.
Learner B3: أنا كنت بس أقول هل بيبقى في مثلا هو يبقى اليوزر يبقى معاه مثلا ممكن تبقى شغالة ومش عارفة ده إزاي برليت للبيجرت بيكتور أو لل سبينس يعني فهل كونسبريشن حاجة كده.
Learner B2: عواضين المفروض في شير موجودة مش عارف لو انتوا جربتوها
Learner B2: لو جربت يعني المفروض إنه في بروجكت ديسكريبشنكو
Learner B2: فأنت لو سألتو عليه مثلا أنا دلوقتي خلصت كذا كذا اللي أنا ممكن أعمله في ممكن يديلك
Learner B2: أوفر يو أو إينسايد كده من خلال قراءته لل بي آر دي
Learner B2: بس كأك شغل طسك هو بيستنى انه ينطر يبعتوا
Learner B2: ابيزنا على بيرفورمانس بتاعكو وال وهكذا
Learner B2: فمش عارف يعني أعتقد في أحيان كتير حتة الوتر فول دي مش مش إنه هو مثلا
Learner B2: اننا بعرف التسكات كلها من اول يوم
Learner B2: بالذات لو حاجة تيكنيكال بقى وبنبني برودكت وجهد كبير
Learner B2: يعني صعب تقولي مثلا أنا في خلال أسبوعين حبعيد طازجة معايا
Learner B2: على قد ما ممكن يقولك أوفر فيو بتاع ال وإلا خلص وإيه مثلا الحاجات المفضلة من خلال ترابط
Learner B2: بس هي فكرة حلوة يعني دي فيتشر ممكن تضاف بطريقة سمارت أكتر ف ممكن ممكن تحصل فيه.
Learner B3: دي حاجة أنا فعلا شغالة عليها يعني عارف هو يبني إيه أصلا أو إيه يعني الماب بتاعته كده حاسة لأ بتفرق يعني.
Learner B2: صحيح يعني مجرد دي بس مش كافي.
Learner B3: قولي بقى يا زينب. كنت عايزة تقوليلي.
Learner B7: كنت عايزة أقول إيه الفكرة من إن أول أسبوع خالص كنا منشتغل على طاست معين بحل لمشكلة معينة وتاني أسبوع تغير يعني إيه اللي بخليكم مثلا تغيروا طاستك فجأة.
Learner B2: هي دي كانت دي بتبقى مع المتر أكتر بس
Learner B2: أنا من وجهة نظري ان ممكن دي تكون
Learner B2: يا إما غلطة تيكنيكال إن توصل غلط
Learner B2: بسبب زي ما قلتلك انش بيكلم تغيرت وبعض الأحيان ممكن حد يعملها
Learner B2: عمدا ان هو يقول مثلا أنا أعمل
Learner B2: دي حاجات بتبقى بتحصل كتير في مجالات عربية في النص كده أعمل كورمنت بس
Learner B2: يعني تكير بيها او تتغير بيها اتجاهها فبتبقى حاجة في يعني ممكن كأنه بيحاكي الفايروس
Learner B2: بس بالنسبة غلطة بسبب الحاجة من غلط فحطها في حتة لا غالب
Learner B2: ف معاكو في الكيس دي تحديدا فاعتقد ان دي مش امتنا دي هنا.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B2: تاني
Learner B2: قلولي برضه إيه ده فيدباكس ممكن
Learner B2: ممكن يعني بعيدا قصدي عن ال فيدباكس أنا ممكن مثلا
Learner B2: حتة يعني كان سؤال عادل. كان لطيف جدا حتة فيتشرز، دي
Learner B2: فممكن مثلا ابعتلكوا كل فيتشرز السوبورت حاليا. موجودة زي تعرفين فكرة الريف نوتس؟ انها يا
Learner B2: عارفين فكرة الإسم اللي هو كأنه سموري كده هذه ممكن برضه ابعتها لكم.
Learner B7: يعني نودس اللي كنا بتتاخد مننا في الرتشو.
Learner B2: لا، دي ، ديترو دي فيدباكس أنا بعتلكوا الحاجات اللي المفروض فيها كل الفيتشرز اللي في المشروع
Learner B2: الموجودة حاليا تيكنيكال في الكود الكود بيعمل كذا كذا
Learner B2: فدي برضو ممكن أعتركم فتبقى أنت برضه عارف الحاجات الموجودة
Learner B2: طيب عارف تشوف اللي انت بتضيفه ده ألريدي موجود ولا لا
Learner B2: كاراليز كاروليز موجودة حاليا برودكتيريز الموجودة دي بتعمل فدي ساعتكم انتوا تقولوا
Learner B2: ان انا كده ضفت حاجة جديدة بالبروت تايب اللي بعمله ولا هو شبه قوي اللي بيتعمل دلوقتي ف
Learner B2: فاهمين قصدي تمام.
Learner B7: مثلا الإعلان اللي بيتعمل عشان خاطر بنستخدمه عشان نعلن عن إن في
Learner B7: ممكن ندخلها. هل الفيديو ده هو نفس الفيديو مش بيتصور كل تحديث أو كل راوند
Learner B7: ولا هو متسجل من أول ما قررتوا تعملوا تنتشر أيا كان الراوند بتاعتها.
Learner B2: لا بيتصور في فيديوهات حتى ساعات منضيف ترينس فا
Learner B2: فاحنا بساعات بنضيف تركس جديدة كمان ف
Learner B2: أو مثلا بنغير منحس إنها منضيف مثلا جديدة أو تولز او بنعمل حاجات تريندي أكتر فا
Learner B2: فالمفروض تصور كل كل راوند يعني حتى إحنا مبارح كنا بنصور الإعلانات اللي هستخدمها فرونت فري
Learner B2: وهكذا صورت انا نفسي فيديو فرونت ون غير اللي ذكرته فيديو فرونت
Learner B2: فالمفروض ان دي حاجة بس إنتو برضو قولي إنه الحاجة اللي ممكن نحسنها هنا
Learner B2: يعني ومش عارف يعني برضه السؤال ده بس.
Learner B3: هو معلش اليدوز
Learner B2: عالإعلانات بتاعة اللي بتنزل عالسوشال ميديا صح كده.
Learner B7: أيوا لا أقصد لما مثلا أنا مثلا لما إخترت دي كان اعلان كدا
Learner B7: لقيتوا كم فيديو أنا عرفت منه الانترنت دي.
Learner B2: أم.
Learner B7: تمام، فأنا كنت عايز أعرف يعني مثلا لو ضفتوا حاجات جديدة مكانش يعني مثلا أنا دخلت مثلا على ان يكون في هيومان مينتر
Learner B7: بيوجهني ب
Learner B7: بساعدني مثلا يعني بشوف أنا من بتاعته أكتر وبيديني فيدباك كمان أكثر ما الإي آي هو اللي حيكون دوره أكبر.
Learner B7: فهل مثلا لما بتحسنو فمثلا، شخص أيا كان بقى بيانا عن النقطة دي ذكرت مثلا فيتشرز تانية وبعد ما خدتوا فيدباكو تحسنت نزلت برضه إعلان قديم مثلا مش بالبيت لحسنتوها مثلا ده حصل قبل كده
Learner B7: هادا كان القطيطين
Learner B7: هل تسمعني؟
Learner B4: انا بس لو حاطع انا بس محتاجة استئذن اي احد محتاج اي شيء اقدر اساعد فيها اكيد يكلموني في اي وقت.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B3: تمام. شكرا على هذا.
Learner B4: والله بس والله هيك سامعني ولا لا أوكي ون مات.
Learner B3: هو عاد انت لسه عندك مشكلة في المايك ولا.
Learner B7: ده مفيد في كانت ازاي.
Learner B3: أنا.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B3: أنا بس مش عارفة يعني إنت كان قصدك طيبي أو إينسايت اللي انتي بتحبي توصله.
Learner B7: بحاول أوصل مدى التوقعات اللي ممكن
Learner B7: الشخص ياخدها من الإعلان اللي موجود ويدخل بعد كده يدي فيدباك سلبي بناء على إيه ما هو دخل بتوقعات إيه أصلا فعشان كده بشوف الحاجات دي
Learner B7: يعني لو لو زودوا حاجة أو لو زبطوا حاجة
Learner B7: بتكون لمسة أوي اللي بيحصل بالظبط ولا شخص بيعمل توقعات أعلى شوية
Learner B7: وبيدخل مثلا الإعلام مش موضح كل حاجة بالتفصيل كنت حابب أطلع بيها التوقعات متطابقة بنسبة قد
Learner B7: ممكن سؤالي ما كانش صح أوي بس دي نسيت عايزة أطلع بيها.
Learner B3: فهمتك بصي عامة أنا فعلا من اللي سألتهم تقريبا إحنا معظمنا ما كناش عارفين أوي الدنيا بتمشي إزاي
Learner B3: أوكي حتى بعد كده يعني دلوقتي في ال إنترنت لما دخلت على الويب سايت حاسه لأ ممكن يبقى في شرح أكتر
Learner B3: أو كده
Learner B3: ففعلا ممكن إن إنتي تتكاثر؟ يعني هل مثلا الإعلانات ممكن يعني توضح أكتر بروسيس ماشية إزاي؟ أو هل في أنا كنت عايزة أسأل برضه هل في بروشور أو حاجة يكون ال يوزر قبل ما يدخل يبقى عارف الدنيا أصلا ماشية الزاي.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B3: معظمنا مش يعني حتى للعارف ممكن يبقى عارف بس مش عارف قوي الزبط.
Learner B7: أيوه ممكن كمان الوصف اللي بيكون موجود في الويب سايت بعد ما مندخل على البرنت أصلا ممكن يكون في جرح أكتر أو بروسيس نفسها تبقى كفيديو كدا موجودة مش مجرد
Learner B7: تعريف صغن كده تحت التراك.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B2: هي نقطة حلوة في لندن كريتش يعني
Learner B2: ممكن تعملوا ديزاين انتو اللاندينج بيج جديدة حاجات دي يعني ده من ضمن برودكت أكيد حتة اللاندينج فيتش
Learner B2: هي طبعا حتة الماركتينغ والإعلانات دي مش في السكوب بتاعكو
Learner B2: بس اللي احنا ممكن نشتغل عليه
Learner B2: هنا نحنا نعمل ديزاين تاني للاندينج بيج فيها.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B3: هو عادل بس عندي مشكلة في المايك وبعد كذا سؤال على الشات حضرتك تقدر تشوف
Learner B3: ونادى كانت بت بتستأذن بس.
Learner B2: تمام.
Learner B3: طيب.
Learner B2: هي الاسئلة لهادي الكبر.
Learner B3: هو كاتب كذا سؤالي على التشاد.
Learner B2: بيقول العربي داخل في الإنجليز فأنا مش شايف قوي. بس ممكن أعرف إذا تعمل أسكوب على أساس إيه ما عنديش مشكلة عندي مشكلة في المي كنت عايز، أعرف.
Learner B7: عايزها في ده عمل السكوب بتاعه أساس إيه.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B2: على أساس. إنه هو مين اللي يرد على تيكنيكال الكوشينز ويعمل جريدينغ للتسكوت
Learner B2: ويساعدك تحل التاسكت يعني بشكل يبقى سوبورت ليك في الحتة تيكنيكال
Learner B2: يعني انا عارف ان انتو كنتوا بتكلموا حتة هيومن وال
Learner B2: بيعمل ريفيو بس ويك ليمن في الستات اللي احنا منتكلم فيها ارت حاليا أو إحنا منستخدمها حتديلك جايدنس وجريدينغ أسرع وأحسن
Learner B2: وده احنا عملنالو فاليديشن يعني بأكتر من طريقة أكيد قبل ما لي بايف معاكم يعني
Learner B2: يعني إحنا قبل ما نشتغل مثلا بال جريدينغ سيستم ده كنا مندرسها كنا بنعملها برضه سكورنج بنفس
Learner B2: كورد مثلا راوند اجس 700 طسك
Learner B2: فكانت غالبيتي يعني بيجي ده مزبوط بقى من ليرنرز وكوتشز كتيرة
Learner B2: هم يعطوا اساسيين ردا على سؤالك هم تيكنيكال سوبورت ده بالنسبة لإيه آيمنت
Learner B2: في اكثر الاماكن نعم، تفضل حضرتك.
Learner B7: لا تفضل.
Learner B2: كنت طيب هو السؤال التاني اللي هو أكتر مشاكل واجهة الراوند دي
Learner B2: هم هم مني مشاكل مختلفة في الديريكشن زي 5 دول فأنا ممكن، أبعتلكم أساميها بس
Learner B2: زي ما قلتلكوا الطقس مثلا مكنش واضحه مثلا مكانش في بعض الأحيان ال
Learner B2: ال ايجينس مثلا تأخرت في كيس في التصحيح. ردت حاجة برا الاسلوب
Learner B2: الخمسة فاكتورز اللي احنا تكلمنا فيهم دول هم
Learner B2: كانوا ثابتين من أكروس الرونز يعني.
Learner B7: أم طيب هل مثلا ايزن لما قررتوا إنتو تخلوه موجود الأسئلة
Learner B7: هل ده بسبب التطور اللي بيحصل إن نحنا بنستخدم ال إي آي في شغلنا
Learner B7: ولا فعلا ممكن يكون جزء برضه بيساعد في القرار ده إن
Learner B7: يعني في لاك في إن إحنا نلاقي هيومان مينتورز شغالين معانا بشكل طويل يعني هم مش شغالين في ال تايم في البرينت مثلا، وعندهم شغل أساسي ثاني وبيساعدوا في برنت كبار تايم مثلا أو شغل بجانب شغلهم.
Learner B2: هو ملش علاقة بالمواكب اوي بسيرش اللي عملناه والتجارب كلها أثبتت إن إن إي آي في حتة فيدباك
Learner B2: اسرع وافضل
Learner B2: وانه يعني بياخد باله من حاجات مثلا لو معمولتينج كويس فيبقى حاجة حلوة وغدا سوف يقول لك هي نفسها وحشة
Learner B2: فبتبقى يعني ده الغرض الأساسي. هو كان إن إحنا نستفيد من هيومن في الحتة اللي هو شاطر فيها
Learner B2: اللي هو مثلا معقدة أو حتى سوشال بروبليم ونستفيد من إي آي في الحاجة اللي هو متميز فيها اللي هي السرعة والأكورسي وال
Learner B2: وهكذا فده كان غرض من استخدام.
Learner B7: مثلا مثلا لو اكتشفت مشكلة إن ساعات إحنا واجهنا مثلا معينين إن لما دخلوا بتوقعات معينة إن هم يلاقوا منتور هيومن بساعدهم وبيديهم نودج من عنده
Learner B7: دي انخفضت عندهم يعني تقاعدت قصر شوية بعد ما لقوا يو إزنت هو المسؤول عن جزء كبير جدا جدا. فلو دي مشكلة كومنت جدا بالناس كتير وكان حلها إن إحنا نوفر هيومن يشاركوا بشكل أكبر
Learner B7: كمان معا فيدباك يعني مش هنلغي كفيد باك عشان يسرع الموضوع لكن الهيمنتور حيكون له جزء مش بس شوية نوليدج صغمنة جدا جوا ميتينج هل دي حاجة تبقى قابلة للتنفيذ ولا هتكون بادجت كبيرة جدا مثلا فحتكون صعبة فعلا. إنها تتنفذ إن إحنا نوافق
Learner B7: هيومنز ده كل تكلفة كبيرة وصعبة تتنفذ ركن.
Learner B2: من طبعا هذا ليس قراري انا بس من وجهه نظري ان برودكت مش محتاج اتعامل بالشكل ده لأنه
Learner B2: مش الهدف منه هو الهدف منه روكسيميليشن
Learner B2: فلو انت عايز نضج ترانسفير فأنت غالبا ما هو موجود في المكان الغلط كورسيس أن أنت بتحضر لشهادة، وبتاخدها
Learner B2: فهو الكورس زي ما قلتلك ال بيزنس
Learner B2: ف فاحنا مش هدف المنتور إن هو يعلمك يعني هو هدفه ممكن يديلك فيدباك يفتحلك تولز زيادة انا كنت منتور مسؤول عن تيم فين
Learner B2: في فروند ونفسيك فأنا كنت برضو بدخل معهم دول وخلاص و
Learner B2: والحمد لله في ناس منهم طلعت واشتغلت وكده لأن هم هم كانوا ياخدوا إنتاجهم
Learner B2: مش جايين يتعلموا جوا ال إنترنت ممكن تكون دي وجهة نظري، ده يعني انت مش محتاج توفر باللغات اللي انت بتقترحي لأنه هو الهدف مشان هو يعلمك
Learner B2: أولا الهدف هناك ويزبطلك سكوت و فيسبوك.
Learner B7: فعلا فعلا حضرتك كلامك صح؟ أنا بس كنت بسأل عشان أعرف يعني مدى الحاجة اللي بتم توقعاتها عند النت اللي برا فعايزة. أعرف أمانج التوقعات دي إزاي بس مش أكتر فده كان غرض سؤالي أكتر
Learner B7: نعم.
Learner B2: أم.
Learner B7: محل.
Learner B2: هو أكيد حتى لو هو أسوأ
Learner B2: لفكرة في ناس كثير بتخاف من التكنولوجي فور ذي سيكور انها بتخاف من التكنولوجيا
Learner B2: او او بتحس ان هو طب ما أنا حكلم جي بي تي بس فده ممكن يكون ماسك كونسبشن عند بعض الناس
Learner B2: بس يعني كل ال
Learner B2: التجارب. وهكذا أو حتى لو آي في حاجات هو بيعملوها كويس فدي يستخدموا فيها وزي ما في حاجات هو بيعملوها كويس.
Learner B2: استخدموا فيها ،
Learner B2: ماشي نرجع للأسئلة أنا عايز أعرف أكتر مشاكل جاوبنا عليها
Learner B2: أمال الخمسة دول كنت فيها نفس الخمس اتجاهات إحنا بنقيس في نفس الخمسة فور واستخدمها وهكذا
Learner B2: الكوميونيكيشنست تيم اللي هو سبورت تيم مثلا وهاجر التوكس الهيومن مينترز طويل
Learner B2: دي كده الخمس حاجات اللي احنا بنبص عليها فإحنا. بنعمل يعني بالنسبالنا بيبقى هو مجرد أفيراج تنشوف ال أفيراج
Learner B2: كم من 5 أو كم في المية
Learner B2: في كل وحدة من الخمسة دول وعلى اساسه بنبدا نقيم إحنا أدائنا عمل ازاي انا ممكن اشيل معاه كل أفيراج الجنرال أفيراج الجنرال كان
Learner B2: ثري بوينت سبت ده للجنرال أفيراج من التوراان
Learner B2: فده كان تري بوينت سفن أو تو فايف
Learner B2: في بقى حاجات ال راوند الراوند الفيد باك أفيراج بتاعها. اتحس ده كنت قلت للمريض. زي
Learner B2: كانت واخدة تريب بوينت فايف بقت واخدة مثلا فور بوينت تو أو فور بوينت فايف
Learner B2: نرى كل حاجه تحسنت او قلت ونحاول نقيم هذا الكيب بتاعنا.
Learner B3: طب هو أنا عندي سؤال معلش هو كان في مشكلة مثلا في الراونز اللي فاتت وإختفت تماما مثلا الراوند دي
Learner B3: أو مثلا كان في نيغاتيف فيدباك كبير قوي وبقى زيرو دلوقتي.
Learner B2: مع زيرو دي لو تقصديها ده معناه ان احنا جبنا 5 من 5 وده مش موجود في عالم ال برودكتمال فلو تقصدي في حاجة احنا كنا جايبين فيها
Learner B2: قريت قليل لو في الراوندي جبنا 5 5 فده يعني لا ما حصلش
Learner B2: والجسم ممكن يكون ما حصلش معاه اي برودكت على المستوى.
Learner B3: لأ أنا مش قصدي كده هو أكيد طبعا مش هراستك أصلا مهما كان في حد يعني
Learner B3: مثلا مش عاجبه حاجة معينة بس أنا قصدي حاجة مايكرو قوي يعني حاجة مثلا كانت مشكلة معينة بعينها مثلا
Learner B3: كانت بوجهوها ودلوقتي مبقتش موجودة.
Learner B2: هي مين الرد. على السؤال ده هي ليست أوف فيتشرز السبعة اللي انا بعتهالكم دول
Learner B2: مثلا بيحطها ويمنعشها فدلوقتي بقت موجودة والمشاكل بتاعتها فدلوقتي مبقتش معلش. أنت بتحجز انت ال ميتينغ اللي انت عايشه
Learner B2: أو تقدر تغيره، برضه بقيت عمل أوتوماتيك مشكراماستر ولا يخش يعمل
Learner B2: حتة إنه بيقعد برد بطريقة مش واضحة. لما بيعطل بيفتي فالحل بتاعها كان يفيد رقم 4 و5
Learner B2: حتة البريفيو فيتشر دي ما تكلمتش عنها بس إحنا بقينا سبورت إن أنا ممكن أديك توكل إن إنت تراجع ل 1 ثاني
Learner B2: فأقدر إننا أقيم ورجعيتك مظبوطة ولا لأ دي برضه حاجة أضفناها وجربناها حتة حتة إن ال شايف ال ويب سيرش وبيعرف يديك معلومات أكتر عن بروجكت وعن الويب وعن الجروب بقى لو سألته أنا مين معي في الجروب والكلام ده كله
Learner B2: فحسلنا الكونتيكست بتاعو فدي تحسينات ال
Learner B2: اللي احنا أضفناه وده اللي تسبب إن هو
Learner B2: فأعتقد دي الحاجة ال سيغنيفيك يعني دي أكتر حاجة أنا شايف إن هي فرقت أوي في ال لأنها مثلا كانت قليلة ودلوقتي وصلت لمستوى عالي ما
Learner B2: أو مستوى أعلى ملحوظ يعني حصل فيها تطور لقيت الحاجات التانية هي أروند أفيراج ثري بوينت يعني في ماضي
Learner B2: الناس في بوينت سفن دي أعتقد يعني
Learner B2: 75 في المية فهي تلاقي حاجات تانية 70 في المية تلاقي كلها في ناس بقى مبسوطة فحطة ثمانينات وتسعينات وفي ناس بتقول لأ
Learner B2: حتى 60 مثلا أو 50 فال أفيراج كان حوالي خمسمية في المية.
Learner B7: طيب هل في مثلا مشكلة اشتغلتوا عليها؟ واتحلت بس ظهرت جانب سلبي سلبي منها على الجانب الآخر وسمعت منها فيدباك بسبب انها اتحلت
Learner B7: يعني دلوقت في مشكلة جربوا تحلوها سمعتوا عنها خلاص النية تحسنت بس كان جانب ليها يعني كان في منها جزء سبب في جانب سلبي تاني مكنش موجود.
Learner B2: ما فهمتش قصدك؟ هل بتوصولي إن في حاجة
Learner B2: مثلا ما كناش واخدين بالنا منها ظهرت يعني اكيد زي مثلا اللينغز دي مثلا
Learner B2: واحنا مش منرد عليهم عشان ف
Learner B2: فقوليلي برضه سؤال ممكن أنا فهمت برضو.
Learner B7: تمام مثلا دلوقتي في مشكلة ما جربتوا تحلوها وتزبطوا.
Learner B7: هل هل في بقى مشكلة لما حاولتوا تصلحوها كان ليها برضه جانب تاني سلبي شوية اثر
Learner B7: فنتج عنه فيدباك في الجانب اللي هي أصدرت فيه مش فيها هي.
Learner B2: لا أعتقد ما شفتش حاجة زي كده لأن هي المفروض الفيتشر لما بتدخل في ام بقى بيعملها ويبقى في برده ساعات وتاخذ أبروفل وهكذا
Learner B2: فيتشر بتبقى معروف ان دي رايحة تحل مشكلة لازم تركت تصيف تايم أو كوست أو تعالي بفتكرش يعني.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B2: انتو برضه لو عندكوا إينسايت أو شفتوا في حاجة حصلت كدا قولولي برضه مين فيدباك. أنا مش كده.
Learner B7: في أسئلة ولا فيدباك مننا بقى زيو زلز بقى.
Learner B2: لا أقصد لو يعني فرق للسؤال اللي انت قلتيه لو انت شفت ان في فوتش اتعملت فعملت مشكله
Learner B2: بسألك لو أنا.
Learner B7: لأ هو.
Learner B2: في حاجة كده حصلت واحنا مش واخدين بالنا
Learner B7: كان ممكن يكون في إجابة مني على السؤال ده لو مثلا ما كنتش سألت سؤال بتاع هيومن مينتور يكون موجود بنسبه قد لأن دي حاجة توقعات أكثر بتاعة الناس اصلا
Learner B7: يعني دي كانت المشكلة موجودة عند بعض الناس رغم إن إحنا حليناها بإن نحنا حطينا إي آي إي سوبورت
Learner B7: الموضوع ويقلل طيب أكتر و يسهل الموضوع ويسرعه ففي ظهرت مشكلة عند يودرز التانية إن هم شايفين إنه إحنا عايزين هيومن أصلا. وكذا فلو ما كنت سألت السؤال ده واكتشفت نمنج التوقعات اصلا كان ممكن أه يكون عندي رد تاني للسؤال ده
Learner B7: بس.
Learner B3: أنا في حاجة عامة. حسن، عندي إجابة زينب
Learner B3: هو كان مفروض أنا هو فجأة الإي آي جت فترة كده كان بيكتب بالعربي وكان بيبقى في ترينز في النص يعني بس عربي فأنا حاسة عشان عربي داخل فكان.
Learner B2: مش واضح هون.
Learner B2: مكانش واضح الكلام أوي.
Learner B3: مش مش موضوع واضح بس هو كان في لخبطة كده يعني كان الجملة مش ما معك.
Learner B7: في حتة النوردج اللي يقدر يساعد بيها مكنتش فعلا قوي بحتة ال
Learner B7: بحيث ان هو بين قوي فمش عارف أتعامل معاه يعني عايز لهجة تكون قريبة من لهجتي زي ما يحاول يعمل معنا
Learner B7: لأ هو كان المشكلة فعلا في إنه عايز نوليدج من شخص هيومن خبرة مثلا مش عارف 20 سنة في الماركت فعايز آخد منه معلومات أكثر ويديني ويوجهني وكذا بس فعلا زي الباش مهندس هتنقال
Learner B7: إنه فعلا دي توقعات المفروض إن هي كان مانجمنت أصلا من البداية المفروض الكلام ده يكون في دبلومة مش في هنا.
Learner B3: آلاء استعمال.
Learner B3: ، قوليه.
Learner B7: فبس خلاص يعني اقصد ان هو فعلا لو ما كنش السؤال ده ترد كان ممكن فعلا يفتح أسئلة ثانية بس أنا شايفة انه خلاص يعني تمام.
Learner B3: فهماكي أنا أصلا كنت بقول على يعني نفس الفكرة بس بقول على حاجة أنا شفتها يعني وحد برضه كان قال ليوسف كده فإنتي بتقولي ده ممكن يبقى كايس ثانية برضه فاهمة.
Learner B7: أيوة فهمت فهمتك؟
Learner B3: طب هو إنتو جربتوا تعملوا تيستينغ على حاجة قبل كده.
Learner B2: نحنا دخلنا 5 يوزرز بعدين سمعتو في السايكل بتعتنا يعني عملنا تيستينج
Learner B3: بس هو مثلا في حل لحاجة معينة،
Learner B3: وكانت مختلفة، تو يوزرز أو في عدد من يوزرز مختلفة عن بقية العدد.
Learner B2: لا معلش مش فاهم انا بس ممكن احتاج اقفل بس يعني ممكن تسأليني سؤال.
Learner B3: لأ أنا كنت بسأل يعني على إي بي تيستينج لو في نفس الوقت يعني حطيتوا في معينة ليوزيرس وبقيت اليوزير حاجة مختلفة.
Learner B2: لأ إحنا كنا بنجرب الإكسبيرس كلها يعني إحنا كنا بنجرب الإكسبيرينس كلها بنفس الموديل على أكتر من
Learner B2: من حدين فاحنا حطينا تيم 1
Learner B2: قلنا ان تيم دة هيدخلوا مع بعض يحاولوا يمشوا في قبل ما نلومش بقى فيش كان بيبقى برودكت كله مش عارف
Learner B2: أنا فيتشر معين إحنا على فيتشر هم ديس سوفتوير تيست يعني فاهم قصدك حاجة سوفتوير تيستينج تيم بتستاهل
Learner B2: وبعد ما بقيت أبروفير إن إحنا تمام كده نطلع لعنده
Learner B2: مش بنعملها تيستينج مع يوزرز إن إنتو يوزرز بتاع بتوعنا الوحيدين فا
Learner B2: إنتو بتدونا فيدبا بعد خلاص انتم
Learner B2: لو في شباك من اليوزر بيكون ضايق.
Learner B7: طيب هل مثلا مرة واجهت مشكلة.
Learner B2: شكرا.
Learner B7: اللي بتعمل في الأول بعد الومبردينغ
Learner B7: يعني هل هل حسيت حقيقية؟ ولا ممكن تشتغلوا على الأسئلة إنها تتغير المطارات ليكوا إينسايت كويسة بحيث انتوا ال تيمز مع بعض أكتر.
Learner B2: الأسسمنت ده يعني ستوري كبير لوحدوا واحنا
Learner B2: بنحاول دلوقتي شغالين على برودكت تاني هو يعني
Learner B2: حاجة تانية يعني طول خلينا نقول طول بديلة للكودر بايت
Learner B2: بتعمل أدابت أوف أسيس وبتدينا بقى أكل بروفايلينغ عن ليفنرز عشان نقدر نوصل الأمور يعني فا
Learner B2: فبيعمل بقى بروفايلينغ عن طريق أسئلة بقى مش فيو فودينغ عن طريق فويس انترفيو،
Learner B2: فمنحاول نحسن في الحتة دي عشان نوصل لبروفايلينغ اكتر
Learner B2: إن إحنا قدرنا نعمل بروفايينج أحسن
Learner B2: فده كان بيخلي ماتشينج والهرمونية أحسن يعني
Learner B2: فإحنا كنا بنعمل ده بيست على أسسمنت بس دايما بتكون المشكلة في الأسمنت برودكست بيديك أكيدة إينسايد فا
Learner B2: فاكتشفنا إن في طبعا إينسايد مش بتتجمع الطريقة المطلوبة أو بتبقى أكلت قوي فبدل.
Learner B7: طيب هل في حد ادنى للخبرة ال المفروض تكون موجودة للشخص اللي هيكون معك؟ في وذكرت المعلومة دي.
Learner B2: ده المفروض إحنا بنعرفه من ضمن والناس دي بنبعتلهم لما كان ريكومينديشن إن هم يروحوا بلاصك
Learner B2: فده بيبقى ديسيجن من ناحيتنا بقى نحنا مثلا قدملنا 50 1 واكتشفنا إن هم في منهم 20
Learner B2: هاي ستروجل في الانترنشن، ف
Learner B2: بنحاول نتواصل معاهم برايفات أو بنبعت لو لقينا الكيس دي متكررة زي ما عملنا معاكوا بعتنا من الناس كلها تقريبا
Learner B2: فيعني ما شايف ان هو بعد أول أسبوع أو بعد شايف ان دي حاجة كبيرة او كده
Learner B2: وشايف هو محتاج يتعلم أكتر فياخذ الدبلما أو بروجرام بتاع سبرينت بلوس
Learner B2: ويحاول يعني يدخل بأفران تانية أو كده فده المفروض حاجة إحنا
Learner B2: لاحظناها و قدمنالها، حل أعتقد غيرنا التريك يعني لحد الناس اللي شايفه انها مش قادرة تكون
Learner B2: فأعتقد الحد الأدنى هو ان انت تكون يعني خلينا نقول
Learner B2: بتاعك أنا مش داخل أستكشف عن قد ما أنا اسبيرينج جونيور أنا
Learner B2: يعني عايز أبقى فول تايم في الحاجة دي ومستعد أدخل إنترفيوز بس شايف مثلا أنا ما عنديش إكسبيرينس حاجة كبيرة. إكسبيرينس أنا أتعامل مع ال تيم إكسبيرينس من وورك نفسه فعايز أتعامل مع منتور
Learner B2: حقيقي شغال في الحاجة دي الحاجات أنا كنت مثلا بتعلم أونلاين في حاجات كورسات أو شهادات وكده
Learner B2: اعتقد دا ال دا أنسب ترسونه للناس اللي تقدر تستفيد منها وتبقى يعني تطلع بالنتائج نعم.
Learner B7: طيب. هل الفيد باك اللي اتاخد إن مش كلش كفاية كان من الناس الخبرات بتاعتهم كانت مستواها كان
Learner B2: لا مختلف المستويات. لأن هي غالبا كان المشكلة في لنجوتش نفسها هي مش محترمة معقدة
Learner B2: حتى لو تسقي سهلة أو صعبة او حد ولا لأ ف
Learner B2: هم الاتنين بيشوفونا لا جماعة تسليم شوفوا ممكن أسمع.
Learner B7: بقدس.
Learner B2: دي كانت موجودة أعتقد من الناس خبرة أو مش خبرة
Learner B2: ما فرقتش أعتقد الخبرة. مش فاكتور قد ما هي اللغة وطريقة ال شرح التذكرة نفسها.
Learner B7: هل في حاجة جت من ناس يعتبر لسا بيستكشفوا المجال هل في توست كان خاص؟ هل في فيدباك كان خاص بالناس دي بس.
Learner B2: أنا ممكن شايف إن أنا مش رضيق إننا أدخل
Learner B2: يعني هو احنا احنا في ناس بتقول إن أنا دخلت لقيت الموضوع صعب
Learner B2: فاتفاجئت بال ريبورمنتسوق وشايف إن أنا مش حقدر
Learner B2: أغطي الكورمنس وفي ناس شافت إن أنا
Learner B2: جوني ألريدي أكتر فأنا مش حستفيد فبالتالي عايز ، تخرجت مالي
Learner B2: اكويت او قليل الانترنشوف عشان أنا عندي نوع من أنواع ل
Learner B2: الجاهزية أعلى من فهي متخصصة. ما قلتلك تارجت برسونا لحد
Learner B2: عايز ياخد إكسبيرينس أكتر من الكورسات فهي بعد ما يخلص الكورس ده حتى الهدف كان من عملها إن إنت بعد ما تخلص الكورس نديلك سيميل
Learner B2: حاجة تستفيد منها وتبني بها مشاريع حقيقية في تيم مع منتور
Learner B2: وتعمل مانجمنت. وهكذا، وتستفيد من خبرة على الواقع مش مجرد إن إنت بتاخد كورس وتسلم تسكوت أونلاين وتعدي شوية فيديوهات وتسكت
Learner B2: اللي احنا كنا مندور عليها بس أكيد طبعا مش كل الناس كانت بنفس فبالتالي فإحنا بنحاول بقى نطور الأسسمنت عشان يتفادى المشكلة دي
Learner B3: أنا عندي حاجة أخيرة بس إحنا مش على حضرتك مضطر تروح دلوقتي
Learner B3: بس أنا عندي فعلا أكتر يعني من أكتر الحاجات اللي جات فيها مشكلة هي إن في ناس بتمشي من وسط يعني من نص كده أو حاجة أو من أول ناس بتمشي فالتسك بالذات المحتاجة
Learner B3: كغروب مش فهل اللي بعد كده هيبقى الكارتية تشتغل أصلا إن لو حد قوي أو مثلا لسه ما يعرفش حاجة مش هيبقى يقدر يدخل
Learner B3: ولا هل إحنا برضه ممكن نشتغل على حلول جنبيها.
Learner B2: أنا أم.
Learner B3: يعني يكون أولا قبل ما يدخل أصلا عارف يبقى مبعثلو حاجة مفصلة الدنيا حتمشي ازاي عشان هو لو حاس إن دي حاجة ما تناسبوش ما يدخلش ويعني يضيع وقته وقت زمايله برضه
Learner B3: دي حاجة مثلا ممكن تتعمل يبقى في برضه
Learner B3: يعني يعني نتأكد إن ال يوزر ده لازم يكون عارف كمان إن هو لما يدخل لازم يدخل كل ميتينغز لازم يعمل كورير كوارمنتس
Learner B3: فنقلل على الأقل فكرة إن هو حد في النص أو في الأول يطلع عشان ده بيأثر على بقية نيوزيرس.
Learner B7: وكان.
Learner B2: تظهر من المفروض تظهر من الأساس من ونقدر نحددها من ال
Learner B2: من المتش يعني ماتش ميكنغ والأسمنت لو بيدونا فرنش بتعد يعني الدينار أكثر يعني المشكلة دي تختفي بالتبعية
Learner B2: فا فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B3: أنا فاهمة بس هي مش كل الناس اللافن مش مناسب يعني ممكن حد يدخل ويحس إن هو لا أنا ليرنينغ ده مش ليا يعني كنا داخلين ومش عارفين الدنيا تمشي إزاي بالزبط فلو حد عرف يعني من قبل الدنيا تمشي إزاي ممكن ده يختصر كثير على كل الناس يعني.
Learner B2: في حاجة ممكن تضيفوها زي ما قلتلكم في دم وفيديو مثلا أو حاجة أو زي ما إنت بتقولي كده في لندن
Learner B2: دي اضافة كويسة من الناس يعني قبل ما تشتري الحاجة تبقى شايفة التفاصيل بتاعتها بشكل أعمق
Learner B2: فتقدر تاخد القرار فتتخذها
Learner B2: يعني المشكلة دي في حد ذاتها. ارتيف فاكت من إينسب ثانية لو اختفت هتختفي يعني إذا كان
Learner B2: إذا كان ال يعني حاجات زي كده.
Learner B3: بالظبط.
Learner B2: بس فدي كلها ممكن تقضفوها برضه في اللدين بيج أو في.
Learner B7: تمام وأنا كمان برضه آخر سؤال طبيعي ولا سؤال يعني غريب انو
Learner B7: بس هل فعلا بيكون هدفكن تباع
Learner B7: شكله أكبر جدا لفئة الجامعات أو حديث التخرج أو
Learner B7: أو الشخص اللي هو الجينيور فعلا تتباع، بشكل أكبر أهم ولا توصل للناس الصح حتى لو بنسبة أقل أهم
Learner B7: بالنسبة ليكو.
Learner B2: هي الأكيد اللي يقدر يجاوب عالسؤال ده اللي بيحددوا
Learner B2: بس هو إحنا أغلب شغلنا بيدو وي
Learner B2: هي الجامعة مثلا اللي بتكلمنا بتقولنا دربوا دول او شركة بتكلمنا عايزين نعملولنا
Learner B2: فدي كانت بتبقى أغلب الكاسس يعني نحنا بناخذ ال
Learner B2: من أونر نفسه يعني فهو احنا هدفنا الواضح هنا هو كان ان احنا نغير أشطر انترنت
Learner B2: من اجل ان شاء الله ممكن بعد هذا يبقى فول طيب فا
Learner B2: بس هو هل بقى الشخص اللي قدم ده هو كان بكفاءة عالية او لا فده ده قراره يعني مثلا لو انا قدمت كان مكتوب عليه الان وكان مكتوب فيه تولز ومكتوب فيه ال سكيلز
Learner B2: فلو في حد قدم، وهو شايف انو هو مش ففي جزء كبير بيوقع عليهم
Learner B2: انه هو اللي قدم حاجة زي كده وهو شايف. انه مش جاهز لأن كانت قبل ما تشترك انه هو في 1 2 3 مطلوب ان يكون عندك قبل ما تم.
Learner B7: بس كانت مكتوبة نايس تو هاف.
Learner B2: كان في حاجات وحاجات مايستوهايف، فهو في حد معا يعني شافك في الماسك ومعندوش كلشي يقدم أصلا.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B2: أنا أحتاج أقفل عشان احنا عاملين لوكينغ على تيم تاني من الساعة السابعة وانا قلته 7، ونص
Learner B2: فأتمنى أكون سايكس كافية ولو في حد عايز زي ما قلتلكم راجع أو يشتغل على عايزني راجع معاه أي حاجة ممكن ان شاء الله.
Learner B3: هو إحنا لو حبينا نعمل ميتينغ قبل الدم يعني كاس في أي حاجة زيادة عادي.
Learner B2: خليها تركيز يعني خلينا نرتب لو ده الناس كلها شايفة إن ده مطلوب ممكن.
Learner B3: ممكن بس.
Learner B7: بتعترف.
Learner B2: بعتها بعتت أنا بعت 3 حاجات الفيتشرز اللي عملناها من راوند تو راوند ون والشركة اللي إحنا شغالين معاها في راوند بنعملها فيدباك فيدباك.
Learner B3: هو ممكن راوند ون وراون تو راوند ثري ولا دي بس كانت أبليكيبل راوند ون وتو حاجة وحدة.
Learner B2: اللي احنا عملناه من راوند تو ون يعني تنقلنا ضفنا الصباح ضفنا 1
Learner B2: فال راوند لي لسه ما جاتش فاحنا لسا ما فرنش.
Learner B3: دول كانوا زيادة على زيرو يعني.
Learner B2: دول كانوا زيادة عن راوند ون يعني راوند ون كنا بادئين بمجموعة من فيتشرز
Learner B2: ضفنا الستة دي عليها عشان تحسن الإكسبيرينس فبالتالي تحسنا في البيت.
Learner B3: ثانك يو سو ماتش ثانك يو على كل ديتيلز يعني.
Learner B2: لا لا عفو شكرا جدا. ليكم يا شباب طبعا التوفيق لكم اليوم بإذن الله.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B2: مع السلامة.
Learner B7: كمركز ستاندرد ميتينج ولا لأ.
Learner B3: مش عارفة بس حاسة هو أصلا حسب صراحة كان مفيد.
Learner B7: معنا ندرة تقريبا.
Learner B7: كل موجود ما عدا ندى.
Learner B3: ندى استأذنت لو لفكرة.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B3: ممكن
Learner B3: ممكن تسأل عالكروب أو حاجة.
Learner B7: ابعت لأحمد منصور في الدقيقة. ما هو يبعتولك على طول.
Learner B3: أنا محتجاه برضه عامة فممكن ابعتلو.
Learner B7: كلنا.
Learner B3: خلونا أه طيب أنا حسب صراحة كان كان مفيد قوي يعني و هذا.
Learner B7: أيوا حصة كمقيم.
Learner B3: أم خلص انتو تمام أوكي عادي كل لك
Learner B3: طيب الباقي حاسين دنيا تمام يعني تمام في كل كله تمام ولا
Learner B7: بدأتوا في التراسكو ولا ده خلاص هينتهي كميتي ستاند أب وكدا.
Learner B3: مش عارفة. أنا كنت بسأل لو إنتو كلو كمان في التاسكو بدأتوا فيه.
Learner B7: بصراحة، أنا كنت حاسة إن أنا
Learner B7: السرفيال اللي كانت تعمل هنا ده يعتبر مختلف يعني دلوقتي أتوقع كلنا نشتغل على من الأول
Learner B7: أريد طاولة عمل على على مشكلة اللي هي موتيفيشن والكلام ده.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: أظن في سبرينت ون وتو ثري فور دلوقتي.
Learner B3: محتاجين. أنا أعمل ديتيلز كده موديل
Learner B3: وبسهم اللي هو آخر تسك لنا بقى.
Learner B7: محتاجين ميتينج قبل ديما داي نفهم وقبلها بفترة كمان يعني بعد بعد ديدلاين ده على طول لو دا آخر أسبوع أتوقع إن إحنا محتاجين
Learner B7: ميتينغ قبل بأسبوع مثلا مش قبلها بيوم كمان.
Learner B3: خلينا زي ما قال كده نمشي ستب باي
Learner B3: خلينا نخلص الباسك بتاعت الأسبوع ده وبس
Learner B3: وجنبيها طبعا والحاجات دي يعني عشان موغود لوكياس
Learner B3: خلاص يعني أي حاجة معاكي و
Learner B3: خلينا نتقابل بكرة إن شاء الله.
Learner B7: تمام أوي.
Learner B3: يلا باي باي.